les nouilles chinoises satin par un
repas des plus fins et ses 55 centièmes
de 0,29 pour les 5 et ça a dû coûter 5
repas du fou je vous emmener là où
j'achète parce que c'est trop cher pour
moi typiquement les épices dans le sens
où ça l'air de rien ce qu'un petit
flacon ça fout de 0,45 et maggie 145 g 5
repas typiquement la viande aussi parce
que c'est
au contraire pour moi je m'appelle l'isi
j'ai 20 ans et malgré le fait que j'ai
plusieurs jobs j'arrive j'ai du mal à
finir les fins de mois et je vous
expliquer comment je fais
je vis dans un studio d'environ 24
mètres carrés
je paye sa 390 euros et du coup là il ya
mon chauffage donc il est caché pour pas
trop y penser puisque j'utilise jamais
parce que ça coûte trop cher c'est
électrique et comment tu fais il est
resté stable à trop froid bah j'ai une
collection de plaids
ça passe encore je m'appelle c'est pas
compliqué je paye mon loyer mes factures
une partie des courses est globalement
lâché à découvert sachant que je
m'appelle le 5 je vais être à découvert
environ
est peut-être le disent nous je vais
avoir 390 euros loyer
environ 45 euros au niveau des factures
pour l'électricité au niveau des
dépenses alimentaires ça va être du 25
30 euros par semaine deux semaines si
j'ai pas le choix j'ai tout ce qui est
des placements et au niveau des
déplacements je pense qu'on peut au
moins compter 40 voire 50 euros par
semaine
juste pour elle en cours ou donner mes
cours je te faire gagner je crois
700-800 avec tous mes taf donc 4 taf est
pas
et on croise sur les orteils pouces je
donne des cours de danse dans quatre
écoles différentes je travaille dans une
librairie je suis danseuse dès que j'ai
du temps du coup ce que j'ai c'est un
reste de crème
ça c'était la charcuterie qui ma maman
m'avait donné quand j'étais passé chez
elle il ya pas grand chose il n'y a pas
grand chose j'ai
paquets de pâtes qui coûte pas cher il
doit me rester une souffle
oui mon reste une il ya un moment où
c'était du pain j'avais une baguette la
moitié de midi la moitié le soir parce
que ça coûte pas cher est-ce que tu
d'achat des fois des fruits et des
légumes
rarement parce que même j'ai même pas le
temps en fait je vais j'essaie de je
travaille à fond pour essayer de gagner
quelques sous donc au final des fois
cuisiner c'est le soir quand je rentre
je suis pas trop crevé
pour voir ça on va faire juste ça deux
hyper fin il ya des moments où où j'ai
faim le matin je nage pas enfin je
prends ma tasse de café et ses jeux des
petits gâteaux qui traîne j'ai mangé ça
si j'ai vraiment faim le midi va déjà je
mange très tard je vais essayer manger
plus vers 16 heures pour faire un bon
repas parce que le charge donne des
cours de danse du coup que j'ai un peu
d'énergie quand même et le soir c'est
plus du grignotage et si juste je mange
pas bien je mange pas et puis tant pis
quoi bien sûr mais pas romaine enfin ma
mère elle me donne ce qu'elle peut comme
elle peut parce que l on roule pas sur
l'or non plus quand elle vient de voir l
machette plein de choses changent et
j'ai souvenir était venu me voir en
spectacle à metz et on a fait trois
courses parce que la vie mon frigo était
vide je vois mon frigo qui déborde elle
n'avait acheté plein de trucs top plein
de petits trucs des épices de l'huile
d'olive ça coûte super cher ville de
livres elle m'avait acheté plein de
choses et je viens remercier mes mille
fois elle me voyait trop heureuse
mais qu'est ce qu'il me regarde ses
amplis s'est remplie et je pense qu'elle
a compris à ce moment là que ce n'était
pas simple et que j'avais du mal à finir
parce que j'ai eu du mal à lui en parler
aussi c'est j'ai pas envie que ma maman
soucieuse parce que j'ai du mal à vivre
et aux mets mes parents mon père et ma
mère ont compris et pas que ma maman
s'ils savent que leur enfant a du mal à
manger a du mal à se payer des choses a
même aller en cours mais eux ça les
inquiète et quand ils sont inquiets
j'aime pas ça c'est du coup le
travailleur libre et je travaille ici
quelques jours par semaine ça par contre
à peu près de 18 heures mais j'aurais
bien on n'est pas nuire dans l'écolo
danse mais après c'est ce travail là qui
nous avait un peu plus de sous pour
vivre joindre les deux bouts le moral du
coût des fois c'est complètement à zéro
aucune envie d'aller au travail le matin
ce qu'au final je travaille du lundi au
dimanche j'ai pas de week-end j'ai très
très peu de jours de repos beaucoup de
choses sont chères su me faire plaisir
c'est payant donc ça veut dire pas de
resto patiner il pas le loisir à côté
vous allez gérer sans - ok on a
travaillé course alliant se passait
[Musique]
je suis donc pop dance aidant les jeunes
du secours populaire je suis référence
nationale donc c'est de 18 à 25 ans et
là bas ce que je fais en gros c'est je
travaille beaucoup avec les jeunes
vraiment laid on va dire on appelle ça
les petits mais c'est les copains du
monde avant 18 ans et avec eux j'ai
faire des tris de vêtements des
collectes je leur donne des cours de
danse on arrive à faire des spectacles
avec ça
je fais la fière oui financièrement je
m'en sors pas mais il ya des gamins que
je vois c'est encore pire que ça peut
sceller le secours qui va les nourrir
avec des distributions alimentaires et
c'est de pouvoir les aider enfin ça me
fait du bien aussi avec eux je me sens
bien j'espère vous voir c'était hyper
cool de travailler avec vous